bonsoir minorité magnani merci d'être
avec nous alors tout d'abord
l'acquittement de laurent gbagbo pour
vous c'est une surprise
bonsoir ou alors j'ai pas tout entendu
mais j'ai entendu le début de vos
questions est-ce que c'est surtout une
surprise cet acquittement de laurent
gbagbo oui alors une surprise finalement
il a été il a été reconnu il avait que
non coupable
donc par rapport aux événements qui se
sont produits la justice a tranché
l'aïe a tranché gbagbo et son acolyte
blé goudé sont reconnus non coupables
à écouter laissons faire la justice
internationale c'est une très bonne
chose pour eux il doit savourer avec
beaucoup de joie ce dénouement
alors est ce qu'on peut parler
clairement aujourd'hui des chèques pour
la cpi alors vous avez d'un côté la cpi
et vous avez le côté la procureure
ça dépend de quel côté on se place si
c'est du côté de la cpi
on peut voir la chose comme une justice
finalement qui va arriver à son terme et
qui va déclarer un homme et enfin deux
hommes non coupable
si parmi les les gens qui ont regardé
cette séquence pendant ces dix dernières
années surtout pendant les deux
dernières années on leur en demande aux
pro gbagbo mais que pensez vous de ces
pays
certains vous diront que peut-être que
la cpi a voulu gagner du temps donc ça
dépend un peu de quel côté on se place
pour avoir une opinion
enfin moi ce que je retiens c'est que le
cpi a déclaré un homme innocent et c'est
une très bonne chose pour le pays la
côte d'ivoire qui mérite du can et de la
paisible cité clairement pour vous la
cour pénale internationale agit en toute
indépendance
normalement oui elle devrait agir en
toute indépendance
je l'espère et on est là pour lui faire
confiance
sinon on ne s'en sort plus sûr fait plus
confiance aux grandes instances qui
dirige notre monde
quelque part on se met en porte-à-faux
par rapport aux décisions et on ne croit
plus rien non rien donc on va leur
donner crédit d'avoir reconnu peut-être
une erreur en gardant deux ans
complémentaires et en dégageant ces deux
personnes de toute culpabilité et donc
ils sont innocents c'est quelque chose
je vous dis qui est formidable on en
parlera peut-être pour la côte d'ivoire
après alors justement se vendent
réconciliation qui souffle sur la côte
d'ivoire est ce que ça peut avoir un
rapport avec cet acquittement tu ça a
été en tout cas peut-être influencé par
ce vent de réconciliation alors ce qui
se passe c'est que le président ouattara
a tout intérêt pour son pays à ce que
son pays redevienne la côte d'ivoire
d'antan et très moderne qui a une
audience qui a une luminosité dans le
dans l'afrique de l'ouest et qui rayonne
dans le monde entier et pour ce faire
s'il réussit la réconciliation alors là
il aura quasiment tout gagné
alors je dois vous dire que qu'il a
nommé un ministre qui s'appelle kdt
ministre de la réconciliation qui doit
agir entre l'ex président gbagbo
l'ex-président bédié pour essayer de
faire en sorte que les trois puissent se
retrouver et que la côte d'ivoire
redevienne cette nation extraordinaire
qui était publicité par le monde entier
pour ses talents qui se trouve au pays
et son développement
va-t-il y arriver il faut y croire alors
clairement est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
maintenant à voir revenir laurent gbagbo
sur le devant de la scène ivoirienne
onetik ivoirienne laurent gbagbo
oui laurent gbagbo est d'abord ivoiriens
ils voient rien donc son intérêt et puis
ce peut être le fait de rencontrer ses
amis
le plu sera retourné dans son pays donc
en côte d'ivoire et je lui souhaite
j'espère qu'il pourra y retrouver
confort amis et pourra y retrouver aussi
des gens avec qui il peut peut-être
reconstruire puisque maintenant le temps
est peut-être de penser à une
reconstruction d'une autre côte d'ivoire
qui sera à l'image de celle qui est
attendu par le peuple c'est-à-dire
paisible et qui soit en développement et
en croissance exponentielle alors si
laurent gbagbo et son ministre blé goudé
ont été acquittés ça veut dire quoi que
les crimes commis en 2011 resteront
impunis alors si si on s'en tient à la
loi ce qui a été fait pour le moment il
n'y a que des supputations ou des
discussions de comptoir qui vont enfin
comptoir et c'est pas péjoratif qui vont
donner les attributions sur la
culpabilité de telle ou telle la justice
internationale a tranché peut-être dans
une sagesse africaine pour pouvoir
permettre une réconciliation
constructive et efficace
laissons à cette institution son choix
et appuyons la merci du 2vic emmanueli
et je rappelle que vous êtes président
l'omg croissance fils merci de nous
avoir apporté votre expertise sur
l'afrique est justement en